hi guys in this video we're gonna talk
about high blood pressure hypertension
okay so where do I start well first of
all there's something called secondary
hypertension which really comes from
something else so let's say for example
you are on KITT analysis you have a
kidney problem kidney damage that alone
can cause hypertension okay but there's
another type of hypertension called
primary hypertension or essential
hypertension or idiopathic hypertension
all these are the same thing and what
this means is it has an unknown cause
okay idiopathic means we don't know what
caused it and there's no cure okay but
there's a treatment right medication and
of course they'll tell you to avoid salt
and your salt sensitive put you in a
diuretic or other medications alright
and then you have something called the
metabolic syndrome which is composed of
high blood pressure hypertension high
cholesterol high sugar belly fat and
insulin resistance okay so that's
interesting well let's take a look if
you research insulin resistance you're
gonna find it has a side effect okay one
of the side effects of insulin
resistance which by the way is high
insulin is high blood pressure in other
words high blood pressure is being
caused by insulin resistance too much
insulin and if you look at metabolic
syndrome all these other diseases in
addition to hypertension and high
cholesterol and high blood sugar and
belly fat these are all symptoms of
insulin resistance so it's very
confusing when you try to do research
because it'll say instant resistance is
an associative factor it might be a risk
factor no no no it's the cause of these
other things right here now let's take a
look at what high insulin or insulin
resistance will do it makes your
arteries stiff now having stiff arteries
and hardened arteries you think that
might increase your blood pressure a
little bit it does it causes sodium
retention yeah
sodium retention okay so and it also
causes low potassium sodium and
potassium
work together when you have high sodium
you're gonna have low potassium
potassium deficiencies will also cause
hypertension but that could be coming
from the incident resistance so I don't
think people are salt sensitive I think
their potassium deficient because they
don't consume enough vegetable you your
body needs 4700 milligrams every single
day yeah to get that potassium you would
have to have between seven and ten cups
of vegetable or salad every single leg
you might not be doing that okay and
that could be part of the problem but
mainly it's the insulin resistance which
will then block the absorption of
potassium and then exaggerate the higher
levels of sodium and create the problem
so what's been the missing link is this
cause effect relationship and the
confusion that is out there on this
topic I would highly recommend start
researching insulin resistance I put
some links down below so you can start
looking at the relationship between
these two and start to improve the root
cause which is high levels of insulin
okay do things to lower insulin 1b start
consuming a lot of salads number two cut
out the sugar because that's what raises
the insulin do in a minute fasting do
the ketogenic program which will lower
your Sugar's so I put some links down
below so you can become more educated on
insulin resistance so you can address
this symptom of high blood pressure
thanks for watching
hi guys listen I want to thank you so
much for your wonderful comments and I
want to ask you if you wouldn't mind
giving me your review on Google I put a
link down below I'd really appreciate it
and thank you in advance